pero renta bicicletas a turistas ha
recopilado la altura en centímetros de
cada cliente y el tamaño del cuadro de
la bicicleta que rentó también en
centímetros después de graficar sus
resultados pero observó que la relación
entre ambas variables es bastante lineal
por lo que uso sus datos para calcular
con una regresión de mínimos cuadrados
la siguiente ecuación que predice el
tamaño del cuadro de la bicicleta a
partir de la altura del cliente y por
acá tenemos esa ecuación de la regresión
de mínimos cuadrados pero a ver incluso
antes de ponernos a leer esta pregunta
vamos a pensar en qué es lo que está
pasando aquí que es lo que ha hecho ver
o ella ha tenido muchos clientes y se ha
dedicado a recopilar información se ha
dedicado a observar qué tamaño de cuadro
de bicicleta escoge cada cliente en
relación con su altura entonces
seguramente tiene una gráfica que se ve
más o menos así en el eje horizontal
tenemos
la altura de los clientes en centímetros
y en el eje vertical tenemos el tamaño
del cuadro también medido en centímetros
así es que por ejemplo aquí tenemos a un
cliente que mide aproximadamente 100
centímetros de altura y rentó una
bicicleta con un tamaño de cuadro de 25
centímetros y bueno la verdad es que no
soy ninguna experta en el tamaño de los
cuadros de las bicicletas así es que no
sé si este ejercicio tiene información
adecuada pero es eso simplemente un
ejercicio entonces supongamos que está
bien ok
aquí estamos suponiendo que ver o tuvo
un cliente que medía 100 centímetros de
altura y rentó una bicicleta de 25
centímetros y entonces ver o puso un
punto aquí pero por supuesto ahorita
pero podría tener otro cliente que mida
100 centímetros de altura y escoja un
cuadro un poquito más grande ok entonces
ver o graficar ya a esa persona por aquí
si éste fuera el tamaño del cuadro
rentado por ese cliente
ya con todos estos datos pero hizo una
regresión de mínimos cuadrados y cuando
uno hace una regresión de mínimos
cuadrados lo que está haciendo es buscar
una línea recta que se ajuste lo mejor
posible a los datos que tenemos
generalmente se usa una hoja de cálculo
o por lo menos una computadora para
hacer esos cálculos y lo que se
encuentra es una línea recta que
minimiza la suma de los cuadrados de las
distancias de cada uno de los puntos a
la recta entonces la línea encontrada
por la regresión de mínimos cuadrados de
estos datos podría verse más o menos así
y por supuesto esto es simplemente una
estimación de qué recta nos quedaría con
esta regresión de mínimos cuadrados pero
puede verse más o menos así esta podría
ser nuestra recta de la regresión de
mínimos cuadrados lo que podría ser la
recta llegó ro igual
un tercio más un tercio por equis así es
que podemos ver a esta línea como una
forma de predecir las próximas rentas de
bici por ejemplo si llega un nuevo
cliente vemos su altura en centímetros
la sustituimos por la equis y lo que nos
queda de esta operación es el tamaño de
cuadro que estamos prediciendo que ese
cliente va a querer rentar esta línea es
una forma de predecir las futuras rentas
de bici pero lo que nos están
preguntando en este ejercicio es cuál es
el residuo de un cliente con una altura
de 155 centímetros que renta una
bicicleta con un tamaño de cuadro de 51
centímetros entonces cómo vamos a
resolver esta pregunta bueno pues el
residuo es la resta del valor real que
obtenemos menos el valor que predice
nuestro modelo ok el residuo es igual al
valor real menos el valor predicho
entonces por ejemplo si el valor que
predice esta línea
grande que el valor real el residuo es
negativo y si el valor real es más
grande entonces tenemos un residuo
positivo pero bueno regresando a este
ejercicio aquí tenemos el valor real
una persona de 155 centímetros renta una
bicicleta con un tamaño de cuadro de 51
centímetros así es que el valor real es
51 centímetros pero nos falta averiguar
cuál es el valor predicho por nuestra
regresión de mínimos cuadrados y aquí es
donde vamos a usar esta ecuación que
calculo ver o porque el valor predicho
por la ecuación de ver o la ecuación de
la regresión de mínimos cuadrados es
igual a un tercio más un tercio de la
altura del cliente pero la altura del
cliente son 155 centímetros
entonces ponemos por aquí 155 ok este es
el valor predicho por este modelo llegó
ro es lo que predice la regresión lineal
y esto es igual a un tercio más 155
entre 3 lo cual es igual a 156 entre 3
que se reduce al entero 52 así es que lo
que la regresión lineal predice es 52
tenemos aquí a una persona de 155
centímetros eso es más o menos por aquí
que renta una bici con tamaño de cuadro
51 que está más o menos por acá pero la
regresión lineal predijo que iba a
rentar una bici de tamaño 52 entonces
aquí tenemos un pequeño residuo esta
distancia es el residuo y también como
podemos ver que el valor real está por
debajo de la línea de la regresión
entonces el residuo va a ser negativo
aunque hay en este ejemplo en particular
tenemos un residuo de menos 1 y tenemos
este residuo de menos 1 y vamos a hacer
un acercamiento para que se vea mejor
tenemos por aquí lalín
de la regresión lineal tenemos por aquí
nuestro dato el 51 el valor real y
podemos observar que se encuentra por
debajo de la línea de regresión entonces
el residuo es negativo y el residuo es
este de acá sabemos que el residuo es
negativo porque se encuentra debajo de
la línea pero la magnitud del residuo es
la distancia del dato a la recta en este
ejemplo el residuo es menos 1 el dato
real menos lo predicho por la regresión
lineal